over the course of the evening we've
seen highlights from eight films
nominated for Best Picture each is
unique and the story being told each is
different in its appeal but they prove
once again that regardless of who you
are or where you live these are films
that connect us to one another once
again here are the nominees for Best
Picture black panther
[Music]
bohemian rhapsody' the favorite
Green Book
[Music]
Wilma
a star is born
vice
and the Oscar goes to Green Book
[Applause]
Greenville has five Academy
winning three Oscars factoring a
supporting role Original Screenplay and
Best Picture
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Aloha
and thank you to the members of the
Academy it's such a privilege this is
like a dream we need to start by
thanking our friends at participant
media who have been with us all along
the way thanks for their belief yeah we
can't overlook Universal and E 1 and
Lionsgate cinetic and Angelotti and i
personally want to thank Kristina and
Maddy and all the Berks and all the
Simpkins we made this film with love and
we made it with tenderness and we made
it with respect and it was all done
under the under the direction of Pete
Farrelly Pete's been an honor
yeah thank you very much you know this
is he's right this is the whole story is
about love it's about loving each other
and despite our differences and finding
out the truth about who we are we're the
same people and this doesn't start by
the way without viggo mortensen right
there we have no movie all these awards
are because Vigo and Maher Sheila and
Linda but it started with Viggo and I
give you this my friend also you may
have noticed I didn't get to thank a lot
of people before it so I'm gonna jump in
I want to thank Steven Spielberg Ron Mar
Bryan and Aileen Roberts Octavia Spencer
[Applause]
Chris powers Donna Langley Jeff small
Tom wolf and Manish Ravel Ella do
Michele bill Kirby who was the first
writer I ever knew
Patsy Haim and Tim Galvin Kwame Parker I
want to thank quarto Wilford I wrote
because of you and I want to thank my
sister Kathy she died a week before we
started shooting this but she never left
my side
okay thanks very much who is for the
Academy but I just want to dedicate this
to our great oh you can't hear me I want
to dedicate to our great friend Carrie
Fisher
[Applause]